the jurogan experience
and
you know
i think we shouldn't be surprised
that physical science has this
difficulty of consciousness because
the scientific paradigm
we've been operating in for the last 500
years was designed by galileo
to exclude consciousness
um should i talk a bit about that yes
so yeah so this is why i defended my
book galileo's era
so really the most important well i
shouldn't say that a key moment in the
scientific revolution right is 1623
galileo's decision that mathematics was
going to be the language of science
right
uh this was the start of mathematical
physics what is not discussed much
is the philosophical work
galileo had to do to get there right
because the problem was
before galileo
people thought the world the physical
world was filled with qualities right so
you have colors on the surfaces of
objects
smells floating through the air
tastes inside food
and this was a problem for galileo
because
you can't capture these qualities
in in the purely quantitative language
of mathematics you know an equation
can't capture the the redness of a red
experience
so galileo got around this so galileo
you know you wanted to describe it all
in math
um
so galileo got around this problem by
proposing a radically new philosophical
theory of reality so we think of galileo
as a great experimental scientist which
he was
but he was also a great philosopher so
he proposed this new philosophical
theory of reality
and according to this theory
the qualities aren't really out there in
the physical world right
they're in the consciousness of the
observer right so if you're looking at
this uh
is that black you're looking at that you
know the blackness isn't really
on the surface of the pen it's in the
consciousness
of the person looking at it or if you're
eating a spicy curry
the spiciness isn't really in the curry
it's in the consciousness
of the person eating it so galileo
strips the physical world of its
qualities
and after he's done that
all that's left are the purely
quantitative properties size shape
location motion properties that you can
capture in mathematical geometry
so so in galileo
galileo's world view there's this
radical division in nature between two
domains
the quantitative domain of science
science you know the physical world with
its mathematical quantitative properties
and the qualitative domain of
consciousness you know consciousness
with its colors sounds smells tastes
which he took to be outside of the
domain of science
so this is the start of mathematical
physics
which has gone incredibly well but i
think what we've forgotten
is that it's gone so well because
galileo gave science this
narrow specific focus galileo
essentially said you know just put
consciousness on one side just focus on
what you can capture in mathematics
so this is so important so i think
people were now living in a strange
period of history where people like sean
carroll for example
think
oh materialism has to be true because
you know look how well physical science
is done you know it's explained so much
surely it's going to explain
consciousness
the irony is it's done so well
precisely because it was designed to
exclude consciousness
so
i think if we if we want to bring
consciousness fully into science
we need a new world view we need to find
a way to bring together what galileo
separated to bring together the
quantitative domain of science
and the qualitative domain of human
consciousness and that's what pan
psychism does it gives it away
i'm not getting how galileo excluded
consciousness that doesn't it doesn't
make any sense i do understand that
mathematics
are what he felt was the underlying
building blocks of all things but even
if you're talking about how like spicy
curry for example spicy curry doesn't
exist in the curry it exists in the
consciousness of someone who eats the
curry but it's not really true because
there's a chemical reaction there's we
know what the ingredients are in the
curry that causes it to have a spicy
reaction to the human being that's
taking it in it's a very distinct very
definable chemical reaction
that we know these plants
have uh excreted these chemicals to
discourage predation that's why they're
so spicy in the first place we know all
these things like this is in a way
mathematics it's mathematics engaging
with consciousness
yeah so look this
there's definitely
a lot we can
we can do mathematically with the tools
in mathematical science yeah you can
capture the chemical composition of the
curry you can capture the changes it
makes in your brain right
but then at some point
the resulting brain activity goes along
with the sensation of spiciness
well you recognize that's where the
miracle happens how is it a sense but
you're recognizing against your pain
sensors in your tongue and the the the
sensations of taste they're all this is
mathematics right like there's there's
certain compounds that cause certain
reactions we even attribute genes to
those compounds like the genes for with
some people cilantro tastes like soap
and some people would taste delicious
like that those are there's a genetic
we we know for sure that there's a
genetic component to that we can
actually isolate the very very specific
genes that cause people to have that
reaction
so i think i think that the chemical
story can the physical story can explain
how people react to the taste how people
store information about it how that
impacts on their later behavior right
but all of that story
could in principle go on
in in what we call a zombie in without
any kind of inner life any kind of
experience of spiciness you you know
it's conceivable that you could have a
mechanism that had all those reactions
um and all those responses but there was
no
feeling of spiciness
um
i mean
he's i mean it's sometimes it's
sometimes a bit more more vivid with
color if you think about so i mean
here's another way of putting it right
suppose
suppose i wanted to
explain in your in a neuroscientific
theory the redness of a red experience
right okay why
red experiences have that red quality
so the first issue is
i don't think you can and this is
essentially galileo's insight you can't
capture
the redness of a red experience in the
language of neuroscience
and the way to see that you know you
couldn't convey to a a blind
neuroscientist
what it's like to see red by
you know getting him to read your theory
in braille right you couldn't convey
that to him so that's a descriptive
limitation right that the language of
neuroscience this purely quantitative
language can't express
the redness of a red experience so
that's just a descriptive limitation
but i think it entails an explanatory
limitation
because if i wanted to
present my neuros my brilliant
neuroscientific theory that explained
the redness of a red experience
my theory would first have to
describe that quality
and then explain it in terms of
underlying physical processes but if the
theory can't even describe it then it
can't explain it so i think in principle
a neuroscientific theory cannot explain
the qualities of our experience galileo
500 years ago realized that and he said
if we want science to be mathematical
we have to take consciousness out of the
story
and that was a good move but we've sort
of forgotten that that's what we did so
now we're in a weird period of history
where people think oh it's gone so well
but yeah it's gone so well because we
took consciousness out of the story
because you can't capture those
qualities
in a purely quantitative language
but what if it's both
what it what if it's
both conscious and chemical that seems
more likely right
yeah but that i mean that's essentially
the pan psychist view right but
look the question is what comes first so
both both the pancitis like myself and
the materialists like sean carroll for
example you know many many people are
materialists we both think
you know in some sense consciousness and
chemicals go together the question is
which is more fundamental i think
that we get physics and chemistry out of
consciousness
we don't do it the other way around it's
it's very easy
to
still understand why you think that
because i think
so we've got a choice well we've got
there's three options really right here
here the three options on consciousness
either
matter is a consciousness is explained
in terms of matter
that's the material
all matter is explained in terms of
consciousness that's the panzerkiss view
or we've got a third option hold on
break that down again
so either either
consciousness can be explained in terms
of the brain okay
that's that's the materialist view of
say sean carroll
second option
no the brain is explained in terms of
consciousness that's my view
right that's the panzerkist view third
option is
they're just they're two separate things
that's the duelist view but it's also
every soul is separate from the brain
everything has some sort of component of
consciousness yeah but this now that's
what i don't understand how do you make
that leap
because i don't
you've gotta you've got these three
choices i don't think i i think look i
basically think the materialist view is
incoherent you you just you can't
you can't account for the qualities of
experience
in in in the in the purely quantitative
language of physical science right
that's galileo's insight aren't the
qualities of experience quantitative in
and of itself
so you i mean
yeah it's good so you
some qualities you can to an extent
capture the structure in quantitative
terms so like color experience has a
mathematical structure we can
analyze it red we can analyze it in
terms of hue saturation lightness and we
can map out a color space
in terms of those three dimensions
spectrum so that's yeah it's not that
they they obviously have that
quantitative structure
but
you can't fully pin down i would argue
maybe you disagree the redness of a red
experience in that language is i mean i
took him a book about the uh the color
scientist not norby who's who's um a
color scientist who's got some cones
missing from his eyes
and so he's only ever seen black and
white and shades of grey but he's a
color expert
and he talks about this and he says
when he tries to think about color
he he compares it to sound so he thinks
of brightness maybe like like loudness
um
and he says he can get some grip on the
the structure
but he says you know i'll never fully
understand
you know
the redness that
that underlies that structure because
he's colorblind because he's colorblind
so so i'm saying the qualities of
experience
can't be totally pinned down in
language example the qualities of his
the
that
experience can be pinned down to a
problem in the structure of his eyes
it's chemicals
yeah we that's we all agree yeah so look
we all agree
that
the kind of experience you have is
dependent on the structure of your brain
right we all agree on that right
that's
but then as the question is what
explains that is that because
the experience is explained in terms of
the brain or is it the other way around
that's the philosophical question
the materialist says the experience is
explained in terms of the brain activity
right i i think that's
doesn't work out
i do it the other way around i think
it's it's much more straightforward at
least to explain the brain activity in
terms of the consciousness but the
quality of the experience can be
explained
based on the way the brain works
so
if you add things to the brain it
changes the quality of the experience if
you add certain chemicals certain
dopamine serotonin you add things to the
experience it literally changes the way
you view an interface
so
so
yeah i agree with what you've just said
which is basically a claim about
correlation
that certain kinds of brain activity go
along with certain kinds of experience
right and certain kind of definitely
are responsible for certain types of
experiences being different well i i
would just say that they go together i
would put it more neutrally they always
go together and that's the science
concert said if you go to a concert and
you take acid
you're gonna have a very different
experience and if you didn't take that
acid absolutely absolutely so so
definitely certain kinds of chemical
activity
go along with certain kinds of and
that's the scientific question the hard
problem of consciousness is why
why do certain kinds of experience go
together with certain kinds of
um sorry certain kinds of brain activity
go together with certain kinds of
experience
and there's two just two ways of
explaining that you explain the
experience in terms of the activity the
brain activity or you explain the brain
activity in terms of the experience